Are you thinking of quitting your job?
Or have you quit your job?
You’re hardly alone.
The world of work is seeing a reshuffle.
Millions of people around the world quit
their jobs during the pandemic - and data
show millions more are thinking of doing
so. Entire industries are finding it harder
than ever before to fill up vacancies. And
attitudes among workers themselves are changing.
And so people aren't forced to work 40 hours a
week at jobs they hate for people they don't like
for jobs that they couldn't care less about.
I think individuals had a lot of
time to sit and reflect and say,
Is my life trajectory going
in the direction I want?
Not only did we lose workers, but
we're not getting fresh workers in.,
In this video, we ask: how has the world
of work changed because of the pandemic?
And is that a better world
for workers - or a worse one?
What do workers want? That’s all coming
up on this edition of Business Beyond.
Now it obviously doesn’t make sense
to treat the world of work as a
monolith - as if all jobs were the same,
and the experience is similar everywhere.
In countries like the United States, the
United Kingdom, Germany and several others, job
vacancies have steadily increased as the supply of
workers appears unable to keep pace with demand.
But these same countries exist in
the same world as those that are
experiencing the opposite
problem: record unemployment.
Where millions of people found themselves jobless
and unable to secure new work -
especially women and young people.
So it almost goes without saying - but your
mileage may vary. That doesn’t change the
fact that the pandemic has reached every
corner of the world - affecting life as we
know it and work as we’ve done it. And that’s
manifested in unique and unprecedented ways.
You might be working from home - or vaccinated
and back in the office - or alternating between
the two. Or you might be considering a switch to
another job with conditions that suit you better.
Over the last months,you’ve probably
seen or heard this phrase a lot
((Great Resignation)). Here’s what that refers
to, straight from the person who came up with it.
The great resignation is a spike in the number of
people voluntarily quitting their jobs in the US
that we've seen from April of this
year, and we have numbers through
August. So about 6.7 million more Americans quit
their jobs during that time period this year
than last year, which makes sense because last
year we were in the middle of the pandemic.
But it's even 2 million more Americans that
quit their jobs during that time period
this year than in 2019, which was the
highest year for voluntary quits on record.
And so it's a spike in resignations that is a bit
unexpected relative to the historical trend lines.
Since he first used the phrase earlier in the year
as a predictor of a wave of resignations to come,
it’s become ubiquitous. And
it’s come to mean different
things depending on who is using it, and where.
Healthcare workers at the forefront of the
fight against the pandemic were applauded
around the world, but are burning
out. The International Council of
Nurses (ICN), which represents 27 million
nurses in 30 countries, has warned that the
so-called intention to leave rate within a
year has doubled to as much as 30 percent.
There’s also been a spotlight on service
industry and logistics workers who,
very often with precarious working conditions
to begin with, found themselves overworked and
overwhelmed by surging demand after the economy
reopened following a period of lockdowns.
When we're all in lockdown and we're
all buying online, manufacturing
goods were very much in demand. So we saw
a shift in workers moving away from these
affected industries to the less affected
industries like manufacturing. But then,
as consumer demand shifted back to services, as
restrictions were lifted, there wasn't hospitality
workers or people to work within the service
sector because they were very uncertain about
the future of these jobs if there was further
lockdowns and they just had moved all together
away from these. So then it left us with a huge
gap when consumer patterns changed once again.
Others think more of workers resisting being
called back into the office after having worked
from home, and for whom anything other than a
hybrid model of working no longer makes sense.
I think the great resignation is where people
who have enjoyed being at home more during
Covid and are going back into jobs that
aren't offering them their flexibility
are choosing to leave and do something else. The
title suggests that they're resigning and going
and doing nothing, which
I don't think is the case.
In March this year, Microsoft released
its Work Trend Index 2021 Survey.
That’s a survey among around 30, 000 full-time
or self-employed workers across 31 markets.
And it said that 41 percent of those surveyed
said they were considering leaving their jobs.
Not surprising perhaps, because the pandemic
amplified existing challenges around work…
in other words it became even harder TO work.
You might have had this in your workplace. You
might have, for various pandemic-related reasons,
fewer people to work with, leaving the
rest of you with a bigger workload than
you would normally have, which leads to
more of your co-workers burning out and
then leaving. Which leaves even fewer
people behind to carry the even bigger
workload which leads to more of
your co-workers leaving and so on.
So the pandemic was unique
in that it kind of burned out
almost everybody in some ways. And we
know burnout is a predictor of turnover,
but the front line workers who were in health
care, retail food service during the pandemic were
reporting high levels of burnout. Organizational
managers and executives who were leading their
organizations through the pandemic were really
stressed. And although there's a lot of upsides
to remote work, there were many caregivers
who were juggling responsibilities personally,
professionally, child care and so forth
that were reporting high levels of burnout.
At the same time, border closures and
covid restrictions hampered migration
- meaning there were just fewer workers around,
especially in industrialized nations,
as it became harder to travel to them.
We've seen quite a lot of disruption to migrant
employees. So a lot of countries around the
world are very dependent on migrant labor to be
able to conduct the activities that they want to
conduct. And so at the start of the
pandemic, we saw outflows of migrant workers.
But we also have seen across the pandemic
disruptions, continued disruption to the inflows
of migrant workers. So not only did we lose
workers, but we're not getting fresh workers in…
And that means companies are having to dig deeper
into their pockets to retain people
- or recruit them in the first place.
So the major impact of labor shortages is the
upward pressure on wage growth. So that is the
immediate impact of the labor shortage that we are
seeing. We see many many companies are having to
bring hiring large bonuses to lure people to the
professions or just to find any workers at all.
That’s good news for workers - and in fact,
the current moment of labor shortages and
elevated resignations are being
framed as a moment where in-demand
workers find themselves with more leverage,
bargaining power, and motivation to organize.
Workers at Starbucks for example, voted
to unionize for the first time in the US.
That has triggered hopes of a revitalized
labor movement in the country.
But some experts fear that
not all the positive gains
may stick - rising wages for
one, may eventually level off.
If they are granted more wages, where is that
passed on to?//The data at the moment, given
the levels of inflation that we're experiencing,
suggests it's being passed on to the customers.//
Once we move out of the transition phase
that we're in, into something more permanent,
everything suggests that more people
are actually going to be at home,
so probably a lesser demand for the services that
are experiencing the wage increases at the moment.
Worth noting that not everything
is about pay - the pandemic forced
changes in the shape of working life,
enabled by technology - and not everyone
is willing to revert to how it used to be.
Here in Europe, a survey of 14,000
people from December showed that only 14%
of European workers want to come
back to in-office work from 9 to 5.
Experts predict that that will mean
companies who do want physical presence
may have to pay extra for it - but that in
turn could have unintended consequences.
Some companies who can afford to pay will give
compensating differentials just to bring people
back into the office// Right. So if you think this
process through, it’s the women who are leaving
organizations that value presenteeism and being in
the office, are the ones that value flexibility in
hybrid working, and they find a home in another
company, probably with less pay because you pay
a compensating differential for hybrid working.
Firstly, the gender gap will widen, and we wonder
why, and nobody will really be able to nail this
down because it's impossible to nail down in data.
In other words - some workers, say
working mothers or disabled people,
might value flexibility over money. They might
not stay in companies that would pay to keep
their employees in the office, preferring
to take the pay cut. That could exacerbate
wage divides and make companies with more
traditional working models less diverse.
But it’s not just how much or how
little flexibility within a job
that has become more important
to workers over the pandemic.
For many people the pandemic
also triggered an internal
re-configuring of values - and placing where
work belongs in that new configuration.
Do I need to be in the office all
the time, or do I even need to have
such an extreme dependent kind of job or
a job that takes a lot of the time? So,
yes, we certainly are seeing the
impact of labor availability if people
are just moving away from different job choices
or that they are just retiring early. That's
certainly something we've seen in many countries
that we've got an aging workforce as it is anyway.
I think individuals had a lot of time to sit and
reflect and say, Is my life trajectory going in
the direction I want? Am I happy? Do I have a
sense of purpose?// Someone else coined the term
pandemic epiphanies, and I thought it was a good
one to capture how people were reassessing the
place of work in their lives, deciding I want to
spend more time with family after the pandemic,
I want to spend more time pursuing my hobbies
and other aspects of myself outside of work.
In other words - the pandemic has gotten
people asking themselves why they’re alive,
and for some, “mostly to work” isn’t
really the answer they’ve come up with.
You might have heard of the r/Antiwork subreddit -
that’s a subreddit for those who want to end work,
are curious about ending work, want to get
the most out of a work-free life, want more
information on anti-work ideas and want personal
help with their own jobs/work-related struggles.
They saw membership surge this year,
with posts relating to quitting
jobs being especially popular.
To give a context to this, we
had around 189,000 last year,
in October of last year, we now have 1.2 million
people. So the uptick has been incredible.
I think uptick is probably under-selling
it as a moderator. But yeah,
I was very surprised when all this was
happening, but at the same time, I wasn't.
Here’s a recurring meme:
Q: What’s your dream job?
A: I don’t dream of labor.
The pandemic has forced a discussion on the
value of labor, but not just in a transactional
sense - it’s helped accelerate a rethink of
society’s relationship with work. Some have
pointed out - there’s a historical precedent
to a pandemic triggering a systemic overhaul.
The black death - or the plague
- effectively ended feudalism.
A drastically reduced population meant
there was less labor to go around. Serfs
found themselves in demand, and less
bound to the estates employing them.
….and the gap between have-nots like
peasants and haves like landlords
eventually became less and less defined.
That’s obviously radically oversimplified.
And not exactly what is happening now.
But the re-examination of hustle
culture in countries like the US,
or the rise of the so-called lying flat
movement in China indicates that the notion
of work as a good in itself is not as obvious
as it once was - as rising housing prices and
recurring financial crises make the gains
from dedicated workaholism less apparent.
To me, anti-work is a philosophy that is aiming to
ideally reduce to zero as much
coercive work as possible.
That coercive element of it is really the most
important part. And so people aren't forced
don't like for jobs that they couldn't care
less about. And for wages that are unfair,
usually in bad environments.
But the anti-work movement isn’t exactly new.
In an essay called the Abolition
of Work by Bob Black in 1985.
No one should ever work.
Work is the source of nearly all the misery in
the world. Almost any evil you’d care to name
comes from working or from living
in a world designed for work.
In order to stop suffering,
we have to stop working.
Maybe NOT all the misery. Or ANY evil. In any
case, stopping work isn’t really an option for
that many people. But stopping suffering
- and promoting wellbeing - definitely is.
There’s more to life than work. There is a certain
amount of privilege attached to being able to say
that. Living costs have to be covered, families
need support, futures must be secured. But perhaps
that is precisely the point - that in a fairer
world, everyone should be able to say that.
The pandemic isn't over, so it's hard to say how
the world has permanently changed. But it's even
harder to imagine things going back to the way
they were. People are simply much more aware now
that work is about the people who do it - and much
more conscious about the systems that govern it.
We have the opportunity to change almost
everything when it comes to how we arrange work.
Let's do it in a way that's fair and equitable
for everyone and fix some of the systemic
problems we had before the pandemic.
And that’s it for this edition of
business beyond. If you enjoyed
our video, don’t forget to check out our
other content. And while you’re at it, hit
like and subscribe. Thanks
for watching and see you soon!